ما فعلناه طوال فترة رئاستنا
هو أننا نظرنا إلى الأشخاص
المناسبين للتعامل مع كل مشكلة ،
ثم نعمل مع شركائنا في مجموعة
العشرين للتأكد من أننا نبدأ هؤلاء
الأشخاص ، لذلك
طلبنا من صندوق النقد الدولي البنك
الدولي منظمة الصحة العالمية
للالتقاء وإعطائنا
بالضبط ما هي الحلول
اللازمة لضمان
التوزيع العادل للقاحات العلاجية
ومعدات الحماية الشخصية التي
حدثت ، فقد دعونا
إلى اجتماع لوزراء التجارة
الذين وافقوا على إزالة
جميع الحواجز حول معدات الحماية الشخصية
التي كانت
حقًا حقًا  مجتمع نادر في
بداية هذه الأزمة
الآن متاح في كل مكان وتتدفق التجارة ،
لذا فإن العمل موجود
وهناك مؤسسات تتابع
للتأكد من أننا
نحقق ما التزمنا به لما
يحدث عندما
يخبر الرئيس ترامب الأمة و  نقول
للعالم أن المنظمات الصحية العالمية
التي نثق في أنها
تتمتع بسلطة كبيرة
ويجب أن يتغير ما
يحدث أعتقد أن العالم لديه
منظمة أه لديه اجتماع
اجتمع واتفق على أنهم سينظرون في
كيف يمكننا إصلاح عملية من
لكنهم كانوا حاضرين كانوا حاضرين
في القمة الاستثنائية  لقد كانوا
حاضرين اليوم ،
نحن نعمل معهم ، حيث تعمل مجموعة العشرين
معهم للتأكد من أننا نستخدم
خبراتهم ،
وأسمع ما تقوله إن
الجميع تمكنوا من ذلك ولكن من الخارج
يبدو أنهم تمكنوا من ذلك على الرغم من
هذا السرد الذي يحاول  تحطيم
الإيمان العالمي بهذه المنظمات
وما يفعلونه ،
ما مدى سهولة ذلك مع
اختفاء الرئيس ترامب ، من
الواضح أن هناك اختلافًا في
الآراء عندما تبدأ في التفاوض على
أي شيء
ثم يتقارب وهذا
ما رأيناه اليوم قاموا بتوقيعه
بالإجماع  في البيان الذي
يتضمن الكثير من الالتزامات
والمبادرات المحددة المتعلقة
بالمؤسسات التجارية متعددة الأطراف ،
منظمة التجارة ليست استثناء على ما
أعتقد  لقد اتفقنا جميعًا على أننا بحاجة إلى
إصلاح المنظمة وقدمنا اليوم ال
طاء السياسي لح
كمة منظمة التجارة العالمية لاتخاذ ال
جراءات اللازمة وقدمنا له
تحت
ج مجموعة العشرين للقيام به.